en este vídeo voy a hablarles acerca de
una fórmula importantísima en
matemáticas esta es una de las fórmulas
más importantes que hay en todas las
matemáticas de hecho hasta se podría
decir que entra en mi top 5 de fórmulas
porque es la fórmula que soluciona todas
las ecuaciones del segundo grado y me
estoy refiriendo a la solución general
de las ecuaciones de segundo grado o la
fórmula cuadrática así que déjame
escribirlo aquí arriba en este vídeo
quiero hablarles acerca de la fórmula
cuadrática fórmula cuadrática muy bien y
la fórmula cuadrática lo que hace es
solucionar todas las ecuaciones de este
estilo a x cuadrada déjame cambiar de
color voy a poner a x cuadrada más bx
más c igual a cero ay que es cuadrada
más bx más e igual a cero en donde la a
es el coeficiente de la ex cuadrada la b
es el coeficiente de la x y la c es el
coeficiente de la x la cero o es el
coeficiente libre es decir constante y
todo esto igualado
y tú ya has visto esto en varias
ocasiones porque hemos trabajado con
esto en muchos vídeos anteriores y lo
que nosotros veíamos en vídeos pasados
era encontrar las raíces de esta
ecuación pues con la fórmula cuadrática
vamos a encontrar las soluciones de una
manera muy sencilla porque la fórmula
cuadrática nos dice que las raíces se
ven de este estilo la equis que buscamos
es igual a menos b más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4 ac entre
2 am y yo no soy muy fanático de que se
aprenda en todas estas fórmulas sin
embargo creo que es muy importante que
tú trabajes con esta fórmula y aunque en
un par de vídeos te voy a demostrar de
dónde sale esta fórmula que por cierto
sale solamente completando el binomio
cuadrado perfecto estaría excelente que
la tuvieras muy fresca que la tuviera
siempre a la mano y que te la supieras
de memoria porque esta fórmula la vamos
a ocupar muchísimas veces para resolver
todas las ecuaciones de este estilo
porque entonces es justo lo que nos está
diciendo esta solución general de
ecuaciones de segundo grado o la fórmula
cuadrática no está diciendo que las
soluciones se ven
de esta manera y bueno para entenderla
mejor sería muy bueno que empezáramos a
hacer algunos ejercicios para que veas
exactamente bien a qué me refiero con
esta fórmula cuadrática así que vamos a
tomarnos x cuadrada más 4 x menos 21
igual a 0 y bueno aquí cuánto vale a
cuánto vale b y cuánto vale s
voy a cambiar de color a va a valer 1
que es el coeficiente que está al lado
de la x cuadrada ojo muy importante
solamente vale 1 no vale x cuadrada b
vale 4 que es el coeficiente que está
lado de la x no vale 4x solamente vale 4
el coeficiente y se va a ser igual a
menos 21 que es el coeficiente libre o
el coeficiente de la x a la 0 y bueno
pues apliquemos la fórmula la fórmula lo
que me dice es que la solución de esta
ecuación de segundo grado es de la
siguiente manera - de m es decir menos
por 4 me da menos 4 más menos la raíz
cuadrada de de cuadrada pero vale 44
elevado al cuadrado es lo mismo que 16
ya esto hay que quitarle menos 4 veces
hacen
vale 1 entonces es menos 4 por 1 por c
pero se vale menos 21 así que aquí voy a
poner el 21 y voy a decir que menos por
menos me da más bueno no de hecho mejor
dejemos ponerlo con mucha calma porque
es apenas el primer ejercicio que
estamos haciendo menos 4 por 1 por menos
21 todo esto dividido entre 2 a 2 por 1
es 2 y por lo tanto esto hay que
dividirlo entre 2 todo esto entre 2 muy
bien espero que hasta aquí vayamos bien
y esto lo que tiene que valer x y ahora
pues vamos a realizar las
correspondientes operaciones x es igual
a menos 4 más menos la raíz cuadrada de
16 menos menos x menos ahora si me da
más puedo cancelar este menos y entonces
me queda 4 por 1 por 21 es 84 84 16 es
lo mismo que 100 perfecto 84 más 16 es
siempre es un cuadrado perfecto y todo
esto entre 2 y bueno entonces me queda
menos 4 más
1010 es la raíz cuadrada de 100 y todo
esto dividido entre 2 y a continuación
lo que voy a hacer es dividir 4 entre 2
y 10 entre 2 y me va a quedar menos 4
entre 2 me da menos 2 más menos 10 entre
2 que es 5 y por lo tanto me está
diciendo que las soluciones de esta
ecuación que tengo aquí arriba las
raíces son menos 25 lo cual me va a dar
3 positivo o en su dado caso es menos 2
menos 5 lo cual me da menos 7 entonces
mis dos raíces es x igual a 3 x igual a
menos 7 que por cierto nosotros
podríamos meter estas raíces adentro de
esta ecuación y verificar que en efectos
sean éstas las raíces de esta ecuación o
en su dado caso podemos hacer lo que ya
sabemos podemos factorizar esta
expresión y decimos dos números que
multiplicamos menos 21 y que sumados me
den 4 pues esto es x + 7 x x menos 3
igual a menos 21 y entonces ya tenemos
los dos números que buscábamos porque un
7 por menos 3 me da menos 21 y 7 menos
tres me da 4 esto ya lo hemos visto en
varios vídeos
no no perdonen perdonen aquí en cero no
es 21 es igual a 0 es una ecuación que
está igualada 0 y entonces nos queda que
x 7 es igual a 0 en su dado caso x 3 era
igual a 0 esto ya lo habíamos visto
varias veces y en el primer caso me
queda que x es igual a menos 7 y en el
segundo caso me queda que x es igual a 3
que que creen son las mismas raíces que
habíamos encontrado y entonces vamos a
decir oye sal pero entonces para que
encontramos todas estas fórmulas y ya no
sabemos hacer pero la respuesta a esa
pregunta es que esta solución general de
ecuaciones de segundo grado
sirven para todas las ecuaciones de
segundo grado inclusive las que son bien
difíciles de factorizar así que vamos a
ver un ejemplo de una ecuación que no
sea tan fácil de factorizar y un
problema en donde me sirva bastante la
solución general de ecuaciones de
segundo grado que por cierto la voy a
escribir aquí la fórmula cuadrática me
dice que x es igual a menos b más menos
la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4
hace entre 2 am y vamos a tomarnos la
ecuación 3x cuadrada déjame cambiar de
color 3x cuadrada más
x igual a menos 10 este es el problema
que vamos a resolver ahora y entonces lo
primero que hay que hacer es igualar
esta ecuación a 0 esto es lo primero que
tienes que hacer cuando tengas una
ecuación de segundo grado y quieras
utilizar la fórmula cuadrática y me
queda 3x cuadrada más 6 x 10 igual a 0 y
entonces ahora sí vamos a aplicar esta
fórmula y para esto hay que encontrar a
b y c este de aquí es am este de aquí es
b el coeficiente y este de aquí s así
que vamos a aplicar la fórmula me queda
que x es igual a quien x es igual a
menos b - b es decir menos 6 v6 y
entonces solamente estoy sustituyendo
estos valores de abc en esta solución
general de ecuaciones de segundo grado
menos 6 más menos la raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada es decir de 6 al cuadrado menos
4 por a por c menos 4 x 3
10 se vale 10 y todo esto hay que
dividirlo entre 2 por a 2 por a pero a
la letra s entonces me quedan dos por
tres muy bien entonces a continuación lo
que hubiese de simplificar un poco esta
expresión me queda menos 6 más menos la
raíz cuadrada de 6 al cuadrado que es 36
menos 4 por 3 por diez lo cual es 120 lo
cual es 120 nos estamos metiendo en un
caso especial pero ahorita van a ver a
qué me refiero 4 por 16 40 por 13 120 y
todo esto hay que dividirlo entre dos
por tres que es 6 y bueno a continuación
vamos a ver cuántos 36 menos 120 lo cual
creo que es menos 84 bueno para estar
seguros vamos hacer la operación aquí al
lado porque nada me cuesta hacer la
operación y así no nos equivocamos y
además vamos a ver cuánto me da de
resultado lo que está dentro de la raíz
para sacar la raíz 6 para cero no se
puede entonces aquí se vuelve 10 aquí se
vuelve 11
es 4 y georg o 84 pero aquí tenemos
menos 6 más menos la raíz cuadrada y no
es 120 menos 36 es 36 menos 120 por lo
tanto resultados menos 84 84 negativo y
todo esto dividido entre 6 y en este
momento más decir oye sal como sacamos
la raíz cuadrada de un número negativo
esto no se puede y bueno no se pueden
los números reales por lo tanto en esta
ocasión estamos diciendo que cuando no
salen raíces de números negativos
estamos hablando de números imaginarios
esto lo voy a introducir en unos vídeos
con mucho más calma para que tengamos
todas las soluciones las ecuaciones de
segundo grado pero ahorita lo que les
puedo decir es que no existen soluciones
reales de esta ecuación no hay ningún
número real de los números que nosotros
manejamos que cumplan que al ponerse en
esta ecuación me dé igual a cero porque
tenemos la raíz cuadrada de un número
que es negativo entonces cada vez que
tengamos la raíz cuadrada de números
negativos aunque pronto sabremos que son
los números imaginarios nosotros podemos
contestar que esta ecuación no tiene
solución o no tiene
más bien en los números reales hay que
tener cuidado que be cuadrada menos 4
hace sea positivo y es que es más lo
podemos graficar y vamos a ver qué es lo
que encontramos nos vamos a encontrar
con una parábola que abre hacia arriba
porque x cuadrado es positivo pero que
nunca cruza al eje de las x así que
déjenme mejor borrar todo esto y pongo
tres x cuadrada más 6 x más 10 y lo que
quiero es graficar esta función recuerda
que todas las ecuaciones cuadráticas
tienen como gráfica una parábola y si
esta parábola no toca el eje de las x
entonces no existen valores que la hagan
celo ahí está ya se dieron cuenta
tenemos una gráfica que nunca se acercan
ni siquiera tantito al eje de las x aquí
está el vértice y a partir del vértice
empieza a subir la parábola para ambos
lados esta función nunca cruza a
legislas x por ninguna parte te das
cuenta mi función baja llega al vértice
y después empieza a subir y es cóncava
hacia arriba y entonces nunca cruza el
eje las equis y es por eso que no
tenemos raíces
en los números reales pero bueno vamos a
tomarnos un último ejemplo y vamos a
resolver este ejemplo y con esto vamos a
entender mucho mejor la fórmula
cuadrática mb a tomar menos 3x cuadrada
más 12 x más 1 igual a 0
a ver qué encontramos de esto y bueno
para esto hay que saber cuánto vale a b
y c ya está igual a cero por lo tanto ya
sabemos que podemos utilizar la fórmula
cuadrática y me quedan menos b pero b es
2 entonces es menos 12 más menos la raíz
cuadrada debe al cuadrado 12 al cuadrado
que 144 12 por 12 menos 144 menos 4 por
14 es decir menos 4 x menos 3
porsche que vale 1 en este caso
vale menos 3 se vale 1 y todo esto
dividido entre 12 como vale menos 3
entonces me queda menos 6 y bueno esto
cuanto es igual a menos 12 más menos la
raíz cuadrada de 144 menos por menos se
vuelve más y cuatro por tres me da 12
entonces es 12 144
156 y a esto hay que dividirlo todo
entre menos 6 y estamos bien 12 144 si
es 156 ya esto hay que dividirlo entre
menos 6 y que me va a quedar bueno
primero que saber cuánto es la raíz
cuadrada de 156 y yo no recuerdo ningún
entero que al elevarlo al cuadrado me
salga 156 por lo tanto lo que voy a
hacer es factorizar lo más que se pueda
el 156 y entonces me va a quedar 156
tiene mitad la mitad es 78 78 también
tiene mitad la mitad de 78 es 39 39 por
2 778 39 39 es primo entonces ya puedo
certificar un poquito la raíz lo que
estoy diciendo es que la raíz de 156 es
lo mismo que la raíz de 2 por 2 por 39 2
por 2 por 39 pero podemos dividir esta
raíz de la siguiente manera la raíz de 2
por 2 por la raíz de 39
24 raíz cuadrada de 4 es 2 entonces me
queda 2 por la raíz de 39 y esta raíz es
un poco más amigable que la raíz de 156
porque si yo sustituyó aquí arriba que
me va a quedar pues me queda menos 12
esto es lo mismo que menos 12 más menos
2 veces la raíz de 39 la raíz de 156 es
dos veces la raíz de 39 entre menos 6 y
bueno qué pasa si divido tanto arriba
como abajo entre 2 esto va a ser mucho
más amigable y me queda menos 6 más
menos la raíz de 39 el 2 con el 2 evans
y abajo me queda entre menos 3 y bueno
voy a separar la división y me queda
menos 6 entre menos 3 más menos la raíz
cuadrada de 39 entre menos 3 y esto lo
estoy haciendo porque menos y menos se
van
esto se puede reducir bastante y 6 entre
13 es 2 entonces me queda dos aquí en un
menos pero menos podría afectar estos
signos sin embargo como tengo dos raíces
una positiva y una negativa es lo mismo
tomar más menos que menos más
lo voy a poner como más menos 2 más
menos la raíz de 39 entre 3 y hasta
ahorita que vamos lo que estoy diciendo
es que la solución general de esta
ecuación es decidir x es igual a 2 +
menos la raíz de 39 entre 3 y quiero ser
bastante claro en este último paso no
quiero que te confundas y medidas porque
quitaste este menos de aquí abajo
entonces lo voy a poner aquí como 2 más
la raíz de 39 entre menos 3 como si
estuviera tomando el menos todavía me
queda dos menos la raíz de 39 entre
menos 3 y fíjate que vamos a llegar yo
lo que te decía es que tenemos más menos
y menos y más pero fíjate que llegamos a
lo mismo me quedaría más entre menos me
da menos y me queda 2 - la raíz de 39
entre 3 y aquí menos entre menos me da
más me queda dos más la raíz de 39 entre
3 que es exactamente lo mismo que dos
más menos la raíz de 39 entre 3 que es
justo lo que teníamos aquí arriba te das
cuenta 2 más menos la raíz de 39 entre 3
por lo tanto este menos era
distinto ponerlo no y lo que quiero que
veas es que estas son las soluciones de
esta ecuación cuadrática que tenemos
aquí es más tengo curiosidad vamos a ver
que nos sale de graficar esta función si
yo pusiera y es igual déjeme borrar todo
esto y es igual a menos 3 x cuadrado
menos 3 x cuadrada más 12 x más 1 y
quiere ver cómo se ve la gráfica de esta
función la gráfica moss iba para arriba
y baja perfecto fíjate tenemos dos
raíces toca al eje de las x en dos
puntos ya ver que no sale fíjate bien
tenemos dos más menos la raíz de 39
entre 3 la raíz de 39 es un poquito más
de 6 porque 6 x 6 636 la raíz de 36 6
entonces es un poquitito más de 66 entre
3 me da 2 esto es un poquito más de 2 y
bueno 2 más 2 con un poquito me saldría
4 con un poquito y dos menos dos con un
poquito me saldría 0 con un poquito es
decir 0 y un poquitito más entonces
fíjate aquí tengo
1 2 3 4 y es lo que teníamos y aquí
tengo al ladito del 0 es decir 0 con un
poquito y entonces estamos bien y espero
que este vídeo te haya sido bastante
útil en donde hemos estado hablando
acerca de la fórmula cuadrática